they are so good
I might cry
hey everyone I'm sabrinaescue and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
first up is the Slurpee it's a little
melted so you can't really tell but
always the ratio is red cherry blue
raspberry top it with red cherry this
was what I got every single day after
school this is the go-to order at
7-Eleven Larkey Park is where we always
played basketball and it was a park in
Walnut Creek that our parents would drop
us off at and we'd go and always noon
ball would be playing and so we'd be
able to go out there compete me and my
brother we used to always play
these old guys for money at the park in
order to go to 7-Eleven and buy Slurpees
and this was always the ratio red cherry
blue raspberry red cherry
next up we have crepes in Romanian we
call Crepes clatite this is a
traditional Romanian snack that my mom
always used to make and still makes
which is just Crepes and then you can
pick what type of jam jelly Nutella you
put on the inside and we would beg her
to make us this after dinner even to
this day we still eat traditional
Romanian food every holiday that's all
my mom cooks there's a lot of meat a lot
of sauces cooked with love enjoying food
with family and friends is kind of our
love language and so every party
everywhere we're at there's always
someone shoveling food down your throat
and that's just kind of part of the
tradition and culture
next up we have Cheetos this is
something that always brings me back to
high school basketball because it was a
joke that we had regular Cheetos and Hot
Cheetos every time someone had it you
could tell because it would leave stains
on your fingers so we would know who at
lunchtime had the Cheetos or the hot
Cheetos and kind of go at that person as
why they didn't share with the rest of
the team
these are crispy I'm still tight with my
high school teammates the snacks that we
used to eat before basketball games
always brings me back to just that time
someone always had Cheetos in their bag
before the basketball game and you just
had to take a handful and pass it around
next up we have another Romanian dish
which is called papanash my mom did not
make these but it was something that
anytime we went to a Romanian restaurant
anytime family went to visit Romania it
was a dish that everyone always enjoyed
having as dessert it's really good I'm
gonna open it up to show you guys it is
literally like a donut ball it's best
like warm out of the oven and then
there's like jam and icing on top it's a
lot of sugar but it's really good
usually you share it if you eat one to
yourself I mean
good for you I guess
these dishes are from the remaining
Garden in Queens I go very often to the
Romanian Garden it's the only restaurant
actually that I know in New York that
has the best Romanian food every time my
family comes in town to watch my games
we at least have one dinner at the
remaining Garden
foreign
next we have
fruit gushers these always bring me back
to high school and middle school as well
because I used to fight over them with
my brother because there's only six
pouches in each box and my mom would
only go grocery shopping once every week
or so it was like first come first serve
I would try and grab as many as I could
when she would come home from the
grocery store and try and get more than
he would
season's all up one second I literally
cry these are so good okay sorry
I usually don't eat like candy sweets
during the season and so
today has been a cheat day being able to
try these fruit gushers but a lot of the
time it's just like real Fruit that I
have
[Music]
well those were like I don't I can't
even explain what I just tasted
[Music]
all right
next we have
authentic Romanian candy this brings me
back to whenever my family would go
visit Romania I have not been yet but
they would always bring back candy and
chocolate is something that always made
it back in the suitcase and so every
time I see these at a store usually like
a European market or store they don't
just have them at Safeway I would always
grab them because they just reminded me
of when I was younger and my family
would go and bring back all the candies
and sweets
[Music]
oh yeah all in Romanian my Serena one
signature sneaker does have some hidden
designs of Romanian calligraphy on them
on just the outsole and the design of
the shoe and that was something that I
was super excited to be able to
incorporate just because it's so much
you know about who I am and how I've
been able to grow up in that household
and entire family you know immigrating
here from Romania I wanted to be able to
you know show that in a shoe
[Music]
thank you everyone for watching me talk
about my favorite Stacks my Serena one
sneaker is out now so go and get yours
foreign
[Music]